We did all sorts of My mom visited
mediums that right after I mean I
haven't done that and I kind of want to
but like she did she went to multiple
mediums
like and both her first husband and
David popped up. Are you serious?
Yeah. And we're like there's a a
17-year-old young man here who wants to
speak to you just do this. She was able
to speak to Don her first husband to
hear from him. I was actually just
thinking about this meeting the other
day. Googling trying to see if I could
find him. I need to ask my mom the name
cuz I would love to go. Brett Cooper,
she's one of the fastest growing uh
YouTubers in recent history. She went on
to Shawn Ryan's podcast and so she was
like 3 hours long. Um he's a phenomenal
interviewer by the way, like really
knows how to ask questions. But yeah, in
this interview a lot of things about her
life came up, including that she had
lost a sibling. So she has a much older
brother, half brother and then twin half
brothers who are also quite a bit older
and one of the tw twins had passed away.
And so
yeah, the mother apparently went to
visit a psychic medium after and said
that she had
seen her son dead son come to her and
speak to her in and her first husband.
the family like where are they at in
their Christianity or lack of were they
I mean were they Christian at this time
or they claimed to be Christian at this
time
at the time I think at the time of the
death from what I understand uh the
parents were divorced and the dad was
orthodox or Catholic okay like
traditional Catholic but the mom I don't
think she was linked to any I don't
think she was Christian or anything
So, in these clips, one of the two clips
we're about to show, she says that she
believes in God. So, I don't know if she
means that she is a Christian, Catholic,
or whatever, but she says she believes
in God. But let's take a look at what
she says about this psychic medium
experience. We did all sorts of My mom
visited mediums that right after I mean
I haven't done that and I kind of want
to but like she did she went to multiple
mediums
like one in New York where you're you
don't tell them or even his assistant
like who you are or anything about you
and you go to this hotel
room and he would just like sit there
was like talking about it is so weird
and both her first husband and David
popped up. Are you serious?
Yeah. And we're like, there's a a
17-year-old young man here who wants to
speak to you. I mean, it was
like I was actually just thinking about
this meeting the other day. Was googling
trying to see if I could find him. I
need to ask my mom the name cuz I would
love to go just do this. But yeah, she
was able to speak to Don, her first
husband, to hear from
him. She had a miscarriage between the
between the boys, I think. And I'm
pretty sure that in one of the medium
things that baby came
in, said something. You know, the lights
just dim behind you twice. I saw that.
I believe it. All that stuff. Me,
too. I know it's real, man. There's not
a there's not a doubt in my mind. Yeah.
Which also is another part of this that
can be very special. Again, it's all
like it's something that's really hard
to hear and it's hard to implement, but
it is about perspective at the end of
the day. If you can think of it as I
will let this drive me. I will be a
better person in spite of this. I will
live for both you and me and I will make
you proud and I will know that you're
always around me. Like that's pretty
cool. It is. Do you think he's here
right now? Absolutely. I think I'm so
like selfish about like he doesn't go a
day without being with me.
Yeah, he's got a bunch of people to
bounce around with, but I'm like, "No,
here.
You're the baby." I know.
Exactly. Need to send it over to my
other brother, though. You need to go
help him. What do you guys think? Is Is
this real? Like, you know, Sean Ryan, he
was saying like, "Yeah, I believe this
is real 100%." And she's like, "Yeah,
he's right here." The light dimmed twice
during the conversation. What can we
understand from this? There's a
fascinating text
in
Isaiah and often times it, you know,
there's
an people quote it, but they don't quote
the the verse before it. Is it this one?
Isaiah 8. Yeah. Okay. That's the one.
Isaiah 8:19 and 20. Um because a lot of
people will quote this last part to the
law and to the testimony. If they don't
speak according to this word, it's
because there's no light in them. Really
when you back up to 19, you see the
context of that. So when they say to
you, "Seek unto those who are mediums
and wizards who whisper and mutter,
should not a people seek their God?
Should they seek the dead on behalf of
the living?" So this is a fascinating
question in the Bible. And you know the
Bible says that it was inspired by the
Holy Spirit or that holy men of old were
inspired by the Holy Spirit. So if we
believe that and and I do then this is
God asking this question Mhm. and God is
saying why are you going to mediums?
Mhm. Why are you going to wizards? Why
are you going to these psychics? Why are
you going to them for knowledge, for
information? Shouldn't you be seeking me
and my
word? And you know that's a that's a
it's a fair question. I mean if we if we
believe that God has all the answers
then we don't need to go to these other
things, right? We don't there would be
no point and and and God is
saying that's not speaking according to
his word. So there's no light in it.
Mhm.
Then you know it's like well if it's not
light what is it? If it's not light it's
darkness. This is true. Yeah. Exactly.
Right. What's the law? God's law is the
ten commandments. What is the testimony?
The revelation says the testimony of
Jesus Christ is the spirit of prophecy.
Yeah. Which if you want to understand
more about that, we can put a link in
the description for a study on what is
the spirit of prophecy. But but but this
is but this is essentially into a
category that God already says, you know
what I mean? Like this is like God has
already said this is off limits. Yeah.
There's there's it's not go and dabble
and test that and see if what they say
is true. He's already said no. There's
no information here that you need. Mhm.
This has already been condemned
essentially. Yeah. And this isn't the
only text in the Bible. There are texts
in
um like Deuteronomy and and Leviticus
and things like that that you know told
Israel, don't Yeah. mess with these
things. Yeah. It wasn't something that
it was taken lightly, right? It was
something that was over and over again
to the point where God did say kill
those Yeah. who who you know talk to the
spirits. even like King Saul, the whole
thing that like God he he didn't listen
to God's voice. So, he went to a medium
to try to talk to to Samuel, right? But
that was like pro the last mistake he
committed in his life and he died the
day after. Mhm. Right. In battle. So,
here's my question for both of you. I I
know what my my answer to this would be,
but why do you think God is so strong on
this?
It's it's dangerous. you know, you're
actually going directly to Satan.
Technically, it's dangerous. Yes, I I
would agree with you. Um, do you have a
Well, I would I would imagine that if
you go to a medium to try to talk to
someone or listen to someone that is not
God, it become it can
become hard to distinguish which God
which voice is God's voice and which
voice is not God. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly.
you're kind of going in the same stream
of thought that that that I am is it
it's almost like God views this as a
dirty tactic, right? Because if he uses
um if he communicates through other
people, right? Um like a prophet or
through a dream or something like that.
And then it could just be anybody. Mhm.
You know, that's that impersonation
that's essentially an impersonation of
God's voice. I think that's why he takes
it so so seriously because he's like,
"Look, if it's coming through a
person, you have no way to tell the
difference except by to the law and to
the testimony. You would have no other
way of knowing." And so, I think that's
why he's like, you know, there's a
certain category of things I'll just
tell you right now, they're not from me.
Mhm. Like you didn't even have to test
that. It's it's not for me. Like
wizards, mediums, psychics, all this
kind of stuff, that's totally off
limits. And then aside from that, if
there is somebody that says, "I speak
for the Lord." Well, you need to test
that. And here's how you test it. Mhm.
But yeah, I think that's why because
it's essentially impersonating God's
voice or speaking on behalf of God.
Yeah. I've never thought about that way
before, but you're right. I I think that
is what is happening. 2 Corinthians
11:14 says, "And no wonder, for Satan
himself transforms himself into an angel
of light." If he can transform himself
into a beautiful looking angel of light,
right? Then could he not transform
himself or his his angels, his fallen
angels could transform into all kinds of
human beings? Probably whatever they
want, you know, whatever they want.
Exactly. And you got to remember that
Satan knows you and knows everybody.
Mhm. So if you're going to a medium and
asking to talk to someone, don't think
that you yourself can be like, "Oh, no,
that's not my brother. He wasn't like
that." Satan knows like exactly how each
person is. Well, even a blind test, she,
you know, she said her mom went to this
psychic in New York and you weren't
supposed to tell him anything. Mhm. But
that still doesn't exclude Satan knowing
all kinds of stuff about you and and
certainly he would know you were going.
Yeah. So he has studied humanity for
6,000 years in order to deceive us and
and tempt us into sin. Surely he knows
how to exactly mimic a person. If we
have actors who can mimic a person to a
tea, we we can fallen angels can do that
a billion times better. 1 Timothy 4:1,
now the spirit expressly says that in
latter days, latter times, some will
depart from the faith, giving heed to
deceiving spirits and doctrines of
demons. So there you go. We know this is
going to happen and we can see the
results of this. And Revelation 16:3,
"And the second angel poured out his vow
upon the sea and it became as the blood
of the dead man and every living soul
died in the sea." It's interesting that
Revelation is actually referring to the
fish to animals as living souls. It
doesn't mean that there's like some like
again some disembodied beings floating
around in the waters or swimming in the
waters. It was just referring to like,
yeah, the fish, they're going to die,
too, because they're also living beings
just like we humans are. Uh, let's look
at the last little clip here of what she
says where she talks about how she
really believes her brother is always
around her even though he's dead. Do you
believe in God?
Do you think your brother's watching
over you?
Yeah. I think of every time I see a
cardinal. Do you know the idea with red
birds that they're Oh, yeah. I know.
And I drive out of our house. We live in
the middle of, you know, the backwoods,
there's one spot where I'm driving out
on this dirt
road, and every single day without fail,
even in like the season when Cardinal
should not be there, drives right in
front of my car.
How does that make you feel? Incredible.
And it wasn't there all the
time. Didn't see him a lot say because I
literally was just like, "Oh yeah,
that's David."
Um, started this summer. I was really
going through a hard time. Felt very
lost.
Um, was really questioning if what I was
doing was right and some, you know,
career decisions that I was going to be
making. And that's when I started seeing
him and I haven't gone a day without
seeing him since. And what did that tell
you? I'm doing okay. Lean into your gut.
Yeah. So, before we get into a lot, what
did she say drove in front of her? A
cardinal. A cardinal. Like a red bird
flew in front of her. Yeah. She says
multiple times throughout the year she's
seen red cardinals. And I looked this
up. Apparently, there is this idea that
when you see a red bird or a red
cardinal, that's a loved one telling you
like they're here. So, but this is not
from the Bible. is from folklore and
mythology.
Yeah. I mean, I
I I'll say this, wanting to
be sensitive to her situation. Um I
haven't probably lost anybody really
that I would say really close to
me,
but you know, there's some things about
that that I think are questionable. Um,
if you're going basically on the same
path every day, like I drive to work
every day and if there was I saw the
same little deer or the same bald eagle
or whatever, I mean, it could live in
the area. You know what I mean? So, it's
like I
Yeah. I just have a hard time putting a
lot of stock in that Yeah. as a sign
that that's your loved one. I mean,
yeah, I don't know if she sees it um,
you know, in the same area all the time
or if she's like driving around the
country and sees it, but either way,
could look at the story of the the witch
of Endor that Saul visited the same
situation that that it made it look like
Saul appeared or Samuel appeared to Saul
when that wasn't the case because that
goes directly.
There's multiple reasons why that's not
the case. One, it goes directly against
multiple scriptures that speak against
that idea of death and the soul and
stuff, but also when you read the
context, you understand more like no, it
can't be. But it's just the idea of like
Satan can create any illusions. So, he
would also have the power to be like,
hey, this person is kind of open to this
stuff. I'm going to keep showing a red
bird. It might not even be a real bird,
but just a red bird that looks like it's
coming across or it could just be a
coincidence or just coincidence. There's
nothing There's nothing wrong with
looking at something and being reminded
of someone. Exactly. No, I'm glad that
you pointed that out. No, I think and
that's and that's where I wanted to be
careful about the sensitivities. I I
think you're exactly right. You know,
when when you believe that your dead
brother is around you. Oh, yeah. It it
comes from the concept of the belief
that he went to heaven and he his soul
is floating out somewhere in heaven. He
comes down to earth to visit you etc.
which opens the door to the belief that
okay I can um talk to him through a
psychic medium you know or like he will
flash the lights on and off to tell me
that he's here. So then naturally you
would have to ask well is this actually
what the Bible teaches and and where
does this idea of an eternal soul
floating around come from? So it it
might be really difficult for some
people to hear this especially when
they've lost a loved one. Yeah. But the
concept of the soul are actually pagan
and not biblical. And we'll go into the
scriptures in just a second to prove
that. But you mean eternal the eternal
soul. Yes. Yes soul. Not the soul. Yeah.
But the soul, how a lot of Christians
believe it's like a separate entity
forever. Yeah. Living forever. Separate
entity that goes up to heaven or to
hell, you know, the immortality of the
soul. Yes. So, uh, the soul concept
actually kind of starts in in Babylon in
the Babylonian era, which Babylon is
also mentioned in the Bible, of course.
Um, there was this idea of Kala, which
was a Mesopotamian underworld. Mes
Mesopotamia is the area of where
Babylonia Babylon was. Um and um it says
the atmnu the spirit or soul was
believed to live in the underworld after
death surviving separately from the body
in a shadowy weak state. Um so this
sounds very much like the idea that we
have today as Christians of like oh
there's a hell there's like an actual
hell burning right now and when you die
this is where you go if you've been bad
basically. Now, if you look at uh the
Greek origins, Plato, he taught that the
soul is eternal. It pre-exists the body
and returns to the spiritual realm after
death. So, it's interesting. He actually
talks about how he pre-exists the body.
Kind of sounds a little bit like what
the Mormons believe of like that you
were like, you know, this spiritual
being before you go into the body and
then you keep going. Um, is it like
reincarnation?
I don't know. They don't really consider
it that, but they have that idea of of
something living before we were even
born as a human. Um, and his his
dualism, the soul is good, the body is
bad, heavily was heavily heavily
influenced later philosophical and
theological thought. Um, and yeah, he
believed in the idea of the immortality
of the soul. You can see that this uh
Greek belief is also found in some
places in the Bible. Uh more
specifically when Jesus is walking on
waters and this disciples think it's a
ghost. Yeah. Right. This belief that
they think Jesus was a ghost is comes
from the Greek belief of the immortality
of the soul. Mhm. Right. That the ghosts
exist and spirits can roam out after
death. Mhm. Yeah. And then it says the
there's Roman pagan origins. So there
was the origin of Alexandria was heavily
influenced by platinism and neoplatinism
and uh believed the soul pre-existed the
body and was immortal. He also started
blending scripture with Greek
philosophy. And then we have Augustine
of Hippo. He was converted from
Christianity. He believed in immortality
of the soul also influenced by Plato and
Plotinus. And he wrote city of God where
he helped canonize Platonic views into
church theology. So you can see once
Christianity came came in that paganism
started mixing and blending with
Christianity and um you know later on
when Roman Catholicism came in which was
also a mixture of paganism with
Christianity this concept of the eternal
soul became even stronger and eventually
became the main belief of all of
Christianity as it was known at that
time. So what does the Bible actually
say the soul is? Well, this is a verse
that we like to use very often. If you
look at Genesis 2:7, it says, "And the
Lord God formed man of the dust of the
ground and breathed into his nostrils
the breath of life and man became a
living soul." So if you look in the
Hebrew, um breath here is actually
ruach interchangeably in the Bible for
spirit or for breath. But you can see
the same idea in Job 27:3 that says,
"All the while my breath is in me and
the spirit of God is in my nostrils."
Does this mean, Felipe, that like God in
his spirit is flying in your nose? No,
you can the breath of life. Exactly. It
would be weird if you thought that,
right? So, it's clearly saying like,
"No, God's breath of life is is
something we breathe in. This is what
gave us life." And if you look at
Genesis 2:7, right, it you basically
come to conclusion of God used dust and
he breathed into our nostrils the breath
of life and we became a living soul. And
then if you look at it in reverse, we
are a living soul. But without the
breath of life, if God removes his
breath of life, we become dust again.
You see the same thing in Genesis 3:19.
In the sweat of thy face, thou shalt eat
bread, till thou return unto the ground,
right? Where we, this is where we came
from. You shall return to this, for out
of it was thou taken, for thus thou art,
and unto thus shalt thou return. I think
it's fascinating
that, and I I looked this up in the
Hebrew just to make sure it was there,
when Genesis says that man became a
living soul. Mhm.
I hadn't really thought about it much
before, but why does it need to put the
word
living? H because otherwise it would be
dead. And by implication, there would be
some a soul that's dead, not living.
Yeah. Right. Yeah. So, yeah, I just
thought that was fascinating when you
think about it. The Bible specifically
says that it became living. Mhm. So, it
didn't exist before and it could be
dead. So, it wasn't pre-existing
floating around. Pre-existing. No, that
would not be biblical according to Yeah.
makes perfect sense. If there's a living
soul, there can be a dead soul.
Therefore, it's not immortal, right?
Otherwise, what you have is God created
a living soul and then when it dies,
that's still a living soul. That doesn't
make sense on any definition if we use
the word death. We don't we don't use
the word death in any context where
death
means it just changed form and it
continues living
except for human beings in religious
context. That's the only that's the only
time I'm aware of where we say death
means it's still alive in a different
form. You know Ezekiel 18:20 says um the
soul that sins it will die it shall die.
Mhm. I mean, it says that um the
consequences of sin in the Bible says
the wages of sin is death. Death. Yeah.
But to me, it's like, you know, if you
just think about it logically, it
doesn't mean anything if death
means life.
Mhm. That's confusing. I mean, it is
confusing because you you'd be using
like circular Yeah. kind of reasoning,
you It's I mean the wages of sin is
living somewhere else or being alive in
a different dimension.
If the wages of sin is death and eternal
life is given to those who give their
lives to Jesus, then if this soul is
floating around in space, even if it's
an eternal burning hell, it's living
forever. It has eternal life. Yeah.
which isn't I mean it's a right which
you know if there was an eternal burning
hell you could see why eternal life
would be a gift but then this is also
eternal life it's just a painful one
but the Bible but the Bible says that
those who will receive Jesus will be
raised up to life and those who will not
will be given eternal corruption
corruption doesn't mean eternal you know
it means eternal death they shall see
eternal death I I agree and and
I'm not saying this to to belittle
anybody. Um I'm just saying the way the
way my mind works when I read all of
those texts
together, I I can't logically and some
people would probably say, well, it
doesn't have to be logical. Okay, that's
that's that's fair enough. But I I when
I look at the Bible, I tend to see
everything line up in a very logical
manner, right? you know this, you know,
you build verse upon verse, you you
collect verses together, everything gets
laid out. It's and I see God as a very
logical God. He's very creative, but it
doesn't mean that he's not logical. And
I think that God does things that make
sense. And so I have a hard time
wrapping my mind around other ways of
looking at this because it's just, well,
A plus B equals C. And I know everybody
doesn't look at it that way. I'm just
saying that's for me, I have a hard time
seeing it another way. Well, the Bible
tells us how to study the scriptures
verse by verse, here a little, there a
little, you know, comparing scripture to
scripture. And so, we cannot take one
verse and say, well, this is what that
means, but it's completely goes against
all these other verses. Everything has
to come together, harmonize, because God
is not a god of confusion. That's
actually what the word babel means. It
means confusion. And God is the opposite
of that. Absolutely. So, Psalm 104:29
says, "Thou hideest thy face. They are
troubled. thou takest away their breath,
they die and return to their dust. So
what happens when you die? It says the
breath gets taken away. God's breath of
life. You're no longer living and you
return to the dust you came from. And I
think in all in all fairness to other
people who have communicated with us,
you know, the way they see these other
texts is, well, yeah, the body dies.
Mhm. You know, and this is the way that
they they harmonize the text that
they're reading. um differently than
than we're harmonizing them. And so they
would just say, "Yeah, the body dies and
returns to the dust and then the soul
keeps on living." But that's still
predicated on the fact that you would
have to establish a soul lives forever.
Exactly. And it says the soul shall die.
And it even says, I think it's in
Ezekiel Ecclesiastes, that um the dead
know not anything. Yeah. So, if they're
floating in space, then how would they
know anything, right? It it does say
it's in Ecclesiastes 9:5 and then it's
in
um what's the other one? It's in 1 or 2
Timothy where it says God is the only
one who has immortality. Mhm. Well, if
you just keep living in a different
form, that's essentially immortality.
Yeah. Whether it's eternal life or
eternal burning, eternal burning or
however you're looking at it, however
you slice that, it's immortality.
But it says God is the only one that has
it. And and it says in in 1 Corinthians
uh 15 that we receive that gift at the
at the second coming. That's right. We
don't we don't get it before that. And
it says that we we seek for immortality.
Why would you look why would you look or
hope or any anything like that? I don't
care what what description you're using
adjective. Why would you uh do that if
you already had it? So I wouldn't seek
for immortality if I already had it. I
would have no need to seek for it. Yeah.
And also it wouldn't make sense for us
to be living in heaven eternally. One to
be looking down upon our loved ones
suffering hurting. How could you have
eternal bliss and happiness in heaven,
which is what hap heaven is all about.
There's no no more tears, no more death,
no more pain. But you're looking at your
family suffering. Or, you know, to make
a little bit awkward, if your spouse
remaries and is personal with another
person, that's very uncomfortable. That
would be awkward. It would be awkward. I
can see how it can be soothing and maybe
even like comfortable to know that your
loved one is looking over you. Mhm. My
mom is still, you know, I'm not alone or
whatever. Yeah. I I I totally get that.
But it's still not biblical. But at the
same time, it does call into question
some other things. It's
like they're And maybe it's just a
presence thing. Maybe it's like, well,
I'm comforted by their presence. But if
they're watching over you, it's not
preventing all the bad stuff in your
life, right? like it wouldn't it doesn't
actually have any function
except you would just you know if it
were true you would just know that they
were watching
but to me that I mean personally I
wouldn't find that I wouldn't find that
comforting and I'm not everybody else so
I I get that but to me that because it's
like you can't communicate with them.
Mhm. They can't encourage you. They
can't I mean you can't see them. Yeah.
Yeah, I mean it would just I mean to me
it's it's not a thing but yeah. Well,
the other thought I had is that um it
wouldn't really be logical like you say
to go to heaven and then Jesus's second
coming is there for the people are still
alive, right? So, and then he like puts
you back in your body so that you can be
resurrected again to go back to heaven.
Yeah. You know it. Yeah. And
Yeah. And then and then what do you do?
I mean there's there's also certain
cases where you I don't know what do you
do with um like Moses
you know he was resurrected and taken to
heaven. Mhm. He was Mhm. And and you
know I mean in all fairness too there is
a there is a belief that um people in
the Old Testament that when they passed
away they were they were taken to shale
and it's it's a lot like a purgatory
type concept. you know, there it's a
holding place. They're there until, you
know, Jesus dies on the cross, makes the
decision, and then they're, you know, in
heaven. But I don't know. The Bible
doesn't tell us, but
um well, no, actually, it does tell us
um Moses was in heaven before Jesus was
resurrected. Mhm. I mean, we see him in
the mount of transfiguration with Elijah
as well. Even if that were true, that
other concept, there's apparently
exceptions to that, at least one. Mhm.
So, yeah, I don't know how that works
either. Yeah, we know that Jesus when he
was resurrected, he took with him the
first fruits and these were the people
who started preaching in the cities to
tell them, "Hey, Jesus." And they were
taken to heaven. We know that. And we
know that Elijah and Moses are in
heaven. We know that Enoch was said to
be translated. Yeah, that's all we know
of all the people that you know. So,
yeah. Okay. So, uh Ecclesiastes 12:7,
then shall the dust return to the earth
as it was and the spirit shall return
unto God who gave us. Again, this is
considering ruach, which is
interchangeably used in the Bible as the
breath of God or the spirit. But also
just again, you have to read in context.
So, if we say, "Oh, the spirit shall
return onto God." Well, that's my soul.
But if you read all the verses we read
prior about, you know, the spirit
actually being God's breath of life and
you read the context of like, hey, every
time we shall return to dust, it's like
all of these things happening, right?
Like we die and our breath of life goes
to God. We die and we and we don't have
the breath of life anymore. Then you
understand when you read the Strong's
concordance and understand the original
word in this Hebrew, it's ru, which is
the spirit. Mhm. So, um, which is the
breath of life of God. Ecclesiastes 9:5,
"For the living know that they shall
die, but the dead know not anything,
neither have they any more reward, for
the memory of them is forgotten." Yeah,
I had this pulled up and there's
um when you look um on either side of
it, you back up to three, it says, "This
is an evil in all that is done under the
sun that one thing happens to all.
Truly, the hearts of the sons of men are
full of evil. Madness is in their hearts
while they
live." Implication is they're going to
die. And after that, they go to the
dead. But for him who is joined to all
the living there is hope. For a living
dog is better than a dead lion.
And then after this this verse it also
mentions also their love, their hatred
and their envy have now perished. Never
more shall they have a share in anything
done under the sun. It I mean that text
seems pretty plain. And and the way I
think about this too is it's also God's
way of telling us the purpose of
spiritualism.
And that is to
communicate information.
Otherwise, why even why even say this,
right? Why does God even say something
like this in his word? The living know
that they shall die, but the dead know
not anything. Like why? Why? I mean,
that seems like a pretty almost random
thing to put in the Bible unless God has
a purpose in it. And I believe he does.
And the purpose is it's a warning. Like
people are going to die. You know that.
Mhm. But the dead people, they don't
know anything. Mhm. And the only reason
you would need to know that is if dead
people were trying to communicate. Mhm.
And so I see it as, you know, a clue as
to the purpose of spiritualism and that
is to communicate information. Mhm.
Which is what a channel is. It was much
older than the TV. Mhm. Yeah. So we
believe that scripture explains death
asleep, right? So we believe a soul a a
s a soul is just us being a living
being. Now, there are actually other
concepts as well in the Bible where it
says my soul. But if you look into all
of those, it says it's like your your
emotions. Yeah. Your personality, your
your inner being. But it's like if I say
to my husband very poetically, my soul
yearns for you. It's not like some inner
being that yearns for him. It's like my
emotions, my affections, my your
thoughts, my thoughts, you know, and and
that's concept comes up many times in
the Bible as well. So there's this idea
of like a living being or or that. Um
but then we also have the idea of of us
being asleep. Now it's interesting
whenever we talk about this, there's
many people in the who in the comment
section say this is not true. the we've
referenced a handful of verses, but
there's actually tons of verses that
talk about the idea of being death being
asleep. Well, let's look at Psalm 13:3.
It says, "Consider and hear me, oh Lord,
my God. Enlighten my eyes, lest I sleep
asleep of death." Mhm. Wait a minute.
This is the terms they were using in
John 11 with with Lazarus. Oh, I have
that, too. Your fun Lazarus sleeps. Oh,
well, let's go wake him up, you know.
And Jesus is like, "No, he's dead."
Yeah. Yeah. You know, and Jesus using it
interchangeably, like, you know, he's
just sleeping. Yeah. Okay. Uh Luke 8:52
and 53, we all wept and mourned for her.
This is another death that Jesus
encountered. Oh, yeah. Uh but he said,
"Do not weep. She's not dead, but
sleeping." And if that doesn't say
enough already that death, death, and
sleep are used interchangeably, it says,
"And they ridiculed him knowing that she
was dead." So Jesus is like, "She is not
dead. She's sleeping." And they're like,
"No, no, no. She's dead. We can see
she's dead." And he's like, "Yeah, but
she's sleeping and I'm going to wake her
up." And Jesus came to conquer death. So
if anyone should know anything about
death is Jesus has the keys. Then John
11:11-14, here's Lazarus. Our friend
Lazarus sleeps, but I go that I may wake
him up. Then his disciples said, "Lord,
if he sleeps, we will he will get well."
However, Jesus spoke of his death, but
they thought that he was speaking about
taking rest in sleep. Then Jesus said to
them plainly, "Lazarus is dead." Yeah.
So, either Jesus is really confused in
Luke 8 and John 11 or or he's making a
correlation. Yeah. Acts 7:60. You know,
I've I was listening to the book of Acts
and this popped up and I was like, "Wait
a minute. I I've heard a story of Steven
being stoned so many times. didn't
realize this actually is plainly laid
out in there as well. Then he knelt
down, he meaning um Steven who got
stoned to death, the first martyr
mentioned in the Bible, and cried out
with a loud voice, Lord, do not charge
them with this sin. And when he had said
this, he fell asleep. Uh 1 Thessalonians
4:13:15, talking about the second coming
of Jesus, right? It says, "But I do not
want you to be ignorant, brethren,
concerning those who have fallen asleep,
lest you sorrow as others who have no
hope." It's not saying those who have
taken a nap or those who are sleeping.
It's talking about those who have died.
For if we believe that Jesus died and
rose again, even so, God will bring with
him those who again sleep in Jesus,
meaning those who are dead, having had
that faith until the end before they
die, that hope of the resurrection. For
this we say to you by the word of the
Lord that we who are alive and remain
until the coming of the Lord will by no
means precede those who are asleep.
Meaning this is really really
interesting. It says we who are
currently alive aren't going to go to
heaven before Jesus comes back and
resurrects those who are dead. Right?
We're not going there before them. We
are all going and and after this it
actually talks about how we will all be
taken up as the Lord. If you keep
reading in First Thessalonians, yeah,
and Paul's using the same terminology as
Jesus, you know, Jesus like, no, they're
they're asleep, but they're making an
important distinction. And I and I think
that's what maybe isn't always picked up
on contextually. They're trying to draw
the difference between a person who
dies and the final death, which is why
they're not probably using the term
death. Death. Yeah. because they're
they're looking at this sense of
finality when when you know the person
is completely destroyed in in death
which we refer to as the second death
after the judgement death. This is this
is where
you're you know this you just you cease
to exist at all. Yeah. You don't wake up
from it. You don't wake up from that.
Yeah. So I think that's why they're
they're using the those correlations. It
helps people understand better. Mh.
Because it Yeah, I'll just leave it at
that. Daniel 12:2 says, "And many of
those who who sleep in the dust of the
earth again, from dust we came, from to
dust we shall go." So we're in the
grave, some to everlasting life and some
to shame and everlasting contempt. Some
tempt meaning everlasting death. We've
referred this to the verse earlier. It
makes a distinction though. Some to
everlasting life, which means some don't
get everlasting life. This is true. This
is so true. So if you're not getting
everlasting life, what are you getting?
Everlasting death. Everlasting death,
which doesn't mean life. Like you can't
use opposite terms to define the same
thing. Mhm. That never works. You can't
say life means life and death means
life. Mhm. So you can't have nobody
like I mean nobody thinks in in that
way. Yeah. You you can't have it's
confusion. You can't have a a an eternal
soul that just lives on after you die if
it's like no that you either have
everlasting life or you have everlasting
death. Because if your soul lives on in
heaven or in hell burning, it's still
everlasting. It's everlasting life. You
can't
have that. If this says either or. Yeah.
So the reformers, you know, a lot of our
our our
um Protestant churches today come from
these reformers that we're about to
mention. And for some reason, they
believed in this idea of of of we are
asleep when we die. And somehow this has
gotten lost over the many years that you
know these these the this Christianity
or these denominations have been into
existence or their followers. Um so
let's take a look at what they believe.
Martin Luther in his in his book uh
defense of his thesis on the power of
indulgences he says it is certain that
to to souls in purgatory no peace is
given according to the cannons that is
to say they suffer torture and horror
this we do not believe and we know that
the dead sleep in peace Martin Luther
the Lutheran came about them and you
know this is what he believed again he
says Solomon judgeth that the dead are
asleep and feel nothing at Oh, I think
he's referring to Ecclesiastes in here.
Mhm. For the dead lie there, accounting
neither days nor years, but when they
are awakened from sleep, they shall seem
to have slept scarce one minute. It's
the same as when you wake up in the
morning. You're like, "Wow, I'm awake."
You were asleep for hours. You didn't
know. You might have been dreaming, but
you didn't know that time had passed. He
also says, "The dead are insensible. The
soul does not live by itself, but all
things await the resurrection of the
body."
Mhm. John Wliffe says, "The souls of the
dead sleep in their resting places and
do not awake or feel anything until the
resurrection." Very smart man.
I think it's interesting is a lot of
these guys were studying at the same
time separately from one another and
coming to the same conclusions
and in the background of having come
from Catholicism
and
questioning those beliefs and out of
that saying that's not in the Bible
that's not biblical that's where they're
coming from. Same happened with Michael
Satler. He was a German reformer as
well. He says it appears that Satler
came to hold the doctrine of
psychopanicism or sleep of the soul
rather than the traditional Catholic
view like you were mentioning, right?
You know, we see the origins of the idea
of an eternal soul are pagan. And you
see that as well with if you understand
history, which is also referred to in
Daniel chapter 2 with the statue of of
of Nebuchadnezzar in his dream, the head
of gold was Nebuchadnezzar and and the
king of Babylon. We saw that this this
whole concept of eternal soul and then
the next kingdom was me um Meo Persia
and then you had Greece Greece took up
the same concept and then it morphed
into Rome more Rome took up the same
concept. So it's just handed down
through a lot of years where it's still
the same idea. And then after Rome fell,
it turned into um pagan Rome turned into
papal Rome, meaning that's when Roman
Catholicism became the ruling power of
the whole world. And um we see that it's
been handed down again, which is what uh
Michael Satler understood.
and William Tindel and ye in putting
them in heaven, hell, and purgatory
destroy the arguments or with Christ and
Paul prove the resurrection. The the
true faith putteth the resurrection. The
heathen philosophers denying that did
put that souls did ever live. And then,
you know, I want to just before we wrap
it up, I want to reference 2 Corinthians
5:6 through8 because in the light of the
soul concept, this is uh uh referred to
a lot. But I'm going to skip to the next
slide where you can actually read this
in context because the problem is when
we study the Bible and we don't read the
context and we take one scripture and
base our theology on that that's
dangerous. But the Bible again explains
itself. So if you read 2 Corinthians 5
1-8 in context, you shall read this. For
we know that if our earthly house, this
tent, is destroyed, we have a building
from God, a house not made with hands,
eternal in the heavens. For in this we
grown earnestly desiring to be clothed
with our habitation, which is from
heaven. If indeed having been clothed,
we shall not be found naked. For we who
are in this tent grown, being burdened,
not because we want to be unclothed, but
further clothed, that mortality may be
swallowed up by life. Now, he who has
prepared us for this very thing is God,
who also has given us the spirit as a
guarantee. So, we are always confident,
knowing that while we are at home in the
body, we are absent from the Lord. For
we walk by faith, not by sight. We are
confident, yes, well pleased rather to
be absent from the body and to be
present with the Lord. We are here on
this
earth. We have a body, right? It's going
to be destroyed and we will have a body
from God, right? This house not made
with hands. I mean, that's the way I'm
understand. So, we know that if our
earthly house, this tent is destroyed.
So, our earthly house is this body. We
know that if this is destroyed, we have
a building from God, a house not made
with hands. In other words, God will go
give us a body eternal in the heavens.
That's the way I'm reading this. For in
this we grown earnestly, desiring to be
clothed with our habitation which is
from heaven. So in other
words, I would much rather have my
heavenly body than my earthly
body. If indeed having been clothed, we
shall be found naked. For we who are in
this tent grown being burdened not
because we want to be unclothed but
further clothed that mortality may be
swallowed up by life. Okay. So in other
words mortality may be swallowed up by
immortality. So it says now he who has
prepared for us this very thing is God
who also has given us the spirit as a
guarantee. So we are always confident
knowing that while we are at home in the
body, so while we're here in this
earthly body, we are absent from the
Lord. Well, that's because we're still
here on this planet. Mhm. For we walk by
faith, not by sight. We are confident.
Yes. Well pleased. Rather, to be absent
from the body and to be present from the
Lord. In other words, what he's saying
is, I have a body. One day this body is
going to be destroyed. Mhm. Um, that's
okay. God has a body for me when this
body is
destroyed. Really, I'd rather have that
body if I could have a body. But until
that
time, while we're at home in the body,
right, he's making a distinction. While
we're still on this earth and have this
body, we're not with the Lord. Okay,
that makes sense because we're still on
the earth. Yeah. And so he's, you know,
when he's saying, "For we walk by faith,
not by sight." Okay. So we know that one
day we will have that body that we
desire, that that renewed body that God
wants to give us. We are confident, yes,
well pleased,
rather to be absent from the body and to
be present from the Lord. In other
words, what he's saying is, I would
rather have that heavenly body and be
present with the Lord than I would have
this earthly body and be present here on
earth. That's the way that reads. I like
how truth about death.com states it,
which link in the description because
they answer every single question under
the sun from scripture about the say of
the dead. So it says Paul likens our
existing mortal bodies with an earthly
tent and says we should not worry if it
is destroyed because we have a building
from God that awaits us. The context
does not support the claim that we will
be in God's presence without a body.
Rather Paul simply says we will not have
this body. He likens our bodies to
clothing that we must wear. In verse
four, Paul specifically says he does not
want to be unclothed without a body, but
rather further clothed, a different
body. That's quite a different picture
than a disembodied spirit that lives on
after death. Mhm. I like that
explanation. And and you know, you can
see this too in Philippians 3:20-21. And
it says, "For our citizenship is in
heaven, from which we also eagerly wait
for the Savior, the Lord Jesus Christ,
who will transform our lowly body, that
it may be conformed to his glorious his
glorious body according to the working
by which he is able to even subdue all
things to himself." So Paul Paul wrote
this Philippians and he wrote
Corinthians and he wrote first or 2
Thessalonians where it talks about you
know how we were we'll be asleep waiting
till Jesus comes and then we will go to
heaven together with those who are still
on the earth and and those who are dead
um in the grave asleep. So Paul is not
going to say one thing and then
contradict it himself somewhere else. It
seems clear from scripture that God
designed human beings to have bodies.
Yeah.
And that even when he comes back and
resurrects those who have fallen asleep
and they get new
bodies that that was the purpose and
design all along. I don't think
God ever intended us for to not have
bodies if that makes sense. Like I I
think again we need to read scripture in
context. like, oh, if you don't
understand this, read the verses before.
Don't take this verse and base your
theology on that. But also, don't read
just the context. Compare it with other
scriptures, the Old Testament, the New
Testament, even the same author. Paul
wrote quite a few books. Again, he
wouldn't contradict himself. Jesus
doesn't contradict himself. Nowhere in
the Bible does it contradict itself.
So we, you know, if this concept
challenges someone at home and says,
"Yes, I see all of this, but there is uh
let's say for example, Lazarus and the
rich man, you know, um there is um I
don't know, you name it. There's a lot
of other stories in the Bible or verses
that people might bring up." Yes.
But that has to line up with this. Yeah.
So the the thing is it's like this. If
you use like a a business example, if
you see a whole bunch of data points
plotted out, Mhm. and you see an outlier
Mhm. you don't make the rule of best fit
on the outlier. You make it on the
collection of the data points, the the
majority of the data points and where
they're going. Now the outlier, you look
at it, you ask questions about it, and
you try to harmonize it with the rest
and see why is it there? Why doesn't it
seem to be with the rest of these?
That's exactly what we have to do with
scripture. We have to if there seems to
be an outlier, like why does this one
say this and I see all these other ones
that say this? This one doesn't seem
like it fits in those. That's how you
establish doctrine is you're harmonizing
multiple scriptures together. You don't
establish doctrine with the outlier. And
you definitely don't establish doctrine
with basing on one verse and not
studying the rest of it. Yeah. That's
the only way we can come to truth,
right? If is if if if we try to see how
does the Bible harmonize everything
else. And if this then all of a sudden
what we've shared doesn't harmonize with
what you've known so far, then that's
not reason to say, "Well, I'm just going
to throw it by the wayside. I'm not
going to worry about it because all of
this." It's a reason to say, "How can I
study this
more to
see how this fits into the bigger
picture?" Last verse. Colossians 2:5.
For though I am absent in the flesh, yet
I am with you in spirit, rejoicing to
see your good order and the
steadfastness of your faith in Christ.
This is not Paul saying I'm having some
out of body experience and I'm like here
with you and I'm here with me. It's like
me saying to you, I'm with you in my
thoughts. I'm with you in my prayers. If
I'm saying I'm with you in my thoughts,
it doesn't mean my thoughts are like
somehow like physically present in your
area and like I'm with you. I'm with you
in agreement. Like I know what you're
doing. I resonate with that. Mhm. And
so, you know, I'm I'm there with you.
Yeah. Or I'm thinking about you and
you're you're on my mind. You know,
that's really what this says. And that
and again, if we take this and say, "No,
but it says in spirit." Well, then we
have to throw out everything else, all
the other verses we looked at to make
this fit. But it doesn't fit otherwise,
right? So, um, we've got a couple of
videos on our YouTube channel because,
like I said, I know there's a lot of
people who might have questions about
what about Lazarus and the Richmond,
what about Jesus preaching to people in
hell? Uh what about near-death
experiences, right? Or the thief on the
cross. Uh we've got some videos on that
for people to look at where we're doing
the same thing. We're just going through
scriptures and comparing scripture
scripture to show how actually all these
concepts harmonize with the the
scriptures we just shared in this idea
that we just shared. Um and also I want
to point out truthout.com phenomenal
website. any question under the sun or
any topic about death under the sun, any
scripture, uh all of these other concept
we just talked about like Lazarus and
the rich man, etc. They're all on here.
You just go to the Q&A and you can find
everything according to scripture. Um
same with ghosttruth.com. Also a really
good resource link in the description.
And also, but we'll throw it out there.
We talked a little bit about hell.
Helt.com does the exact same thing. Um
and again, verse by verse by verse. love
that about these websites that it's not
human interpretation, it's the Bible
explaining itself. If you like this
video, like, subscribe, and hit the
notification bell so you know when we
launch new videos. And drop a comments
below, and we'll try to get back to you
if we can. What?
Say that again. No. No. I don't know
what to say.
[Music]